i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
pensaba dentro de lo incierto que cada
uno transita en nuestra vida
como la identidad es algo incierto
quiénes somos quién soy qué es la
identidad un aspecto fundamental de
nuestra vida si uno buscará en el
diccionario de la real academia española
el significado de la palabra identidad
se encontraría con que dice condición de
ser una persona y no otra
ser quien uno que en una es y no otra
persona
bastante simple no pareciera la
definición bastante simple de leer en el
diccionario bastante complejo de vivir
cada uno cada una de nosotros y nosotras
sabemos lo difícil que es transitar la
identidad la identidad es un proceso
complejo multidimensional y tan personal
que incluso para el ámbito del derecho
se considera un derecho personalísimo
imagínense ustedes algo efectivamente
propio
cuántas veces nos habremos preguntado
por qué somos de tal o cual manera por
qué actuamos de tal o cual modo que nos
habrá pasado para hacer cómo somos
será que se aprenden los aspectos de la
identidad
será que nos pasa algo que determina
cómo somos
será que lo vemos en nuestra vida
cotidiana o vendrá innato vendrá con
nosotros
como es esta experiencia de ser
porque somos de un modo en otro porque
somos esa persona y no otra y quién sabe
mejor que nadie si yo les preguntara a
ustedes piense en un minuto
quién puede saber mejor que nadie quién
es cada uno y cada una de nosotros y
nosotras
seguramente la respuesta que encontrarán
es que uno mismo es quien sabe quién es
y efectivamente la identidad ese es el
camino y ese proceso personal
por supuesto que puede haber algunos
aspectos de la identidad que se han
aprendido seguramente modos de ver la
vida preferencias profesionales o
personales hasta un club de fútbol
aspectos que hacen a nuestra identidad y
que seguramente vamos aprendiendo en la
familia en el club en la escuela en los
medios de comunicación en los ámbitos en
los que nos movemos
yo voy a hablar también un poco de mi
propia identidad para que me conozcan un
poco más cuando me presentaron les
dijeron les contaron que me llamo
esteban paulón ahí hay un primer rasgo
de mi identidad fundamental porque es el
que me permite identificarme ante
ustedes mi nombre me llamo esteban
el nombre eso no lo elegí obviamente me
lo eligieron mi papá y mi mamá
tengo 41 años tampoco elegí cuando nacer
así que la edad por tanto no la puedo
elegir nací en concordia entre ríos otro
aspecto de la vida que no pude elegir
por trabajo de mis padres nací allí soy
tercer hermano de cuatro hermanos
varones
soy de river quizá ese aspecto si lo
puede elegir aunque en realidad creo que
fue por imitación de mi hermano mayor
pero que idealizamos cuando somos chicos
a los hermanos mayores mi hermano mayor
se llama estanislao era the river el
único the river de la familia y yo me
hice the river
me gusta viajar me gustan las novelas
policiales tanto en la tele netflix todo
el tiempo siempre hay alguna nueva pero
cuando era chico leía los libros de
agatha christie hércules poirot el
detective belga
muchos aspectos de mi identidad
múltiples aspectos de mi identidad y
seguramente si cada uno cada una de
ustedes piensa sobre sí mismo va a
encontrar aspectos similares
y hay otro aspecto muy importante en mi
identidad que quiero compartir también
con ustedes hace nueve años estoy en
pareja hace cinco me casé por la ley del
matrimonio igualitario que es una ley
que se aprueba en argentina en el año
2010 y que permite que dos personas
cualquiera sea su sexo su género se
puedan casar un hombre con un hombre una
mujer con una mujer un hombre con una
mujer ahora el matrimonio es un derecho
al cual podemos acceder todas y todos
yo me casé hace cinco años igual que
cualquier otro matrimonio con fiesta
música familia amigos amigas
quieren saber cómo se llama mi pareja
y para ello llama pablo y yo soy esteban
estoy casado con pablo por supuesto soy
un varón gay seguramente la mayoría de
ustedes lo supondría o lo sabe porque
aparte en la propia presentación me
presentaron como activista del
movimiento de gays lesbianas bisexuales
y personas trans
pero estoy compartiendo con ustedes
también algo más de información de un
aspecto muy importante de mi identidad
mi orientación sexual la orientación
sexual es un aspecto de la identidad que
determina quién nos va a traer quién nos
va a gustar de quién nos vamos a
enamorar quién nos va a utilizar quién
nos va a mover el piso quién nos va a
llenar el estómago de mariposas tengo
mariposas en la panza decíamos cuando
éramos chicos cuando alguien nos gustaba
y es tan importante la orientación
sexual en la vida de cada uno y cada uno
de nosotros y nosotras que todos y todas
tenemos una orientación sexual a veces
pareciera que los únicos que tenemos
orientación sexual somos los gays
lesbianas bisexuales trans la
heterosexualidad también es una
orientación sexual
también gustar de una persona de un
género diferente es expresar nuestra
propia orientación sexual lo que pasa es
que como es lo más frecuente lo más
común lo que vemos habitualmente lo que
leemos en los cuentos lo que vemos en
las novelas de la tele
seguramente nos llama tanto la atención
cuántas veces escuchamos eso de que los
heterosexuales no andan diciendo por
allí que son heterosexuales seguramente
lo escuchamos muchísimas veces y sin
embargo cuando vemos una pareja de la
mano en la calle nos está contando con
ese gesto qué es una pareja heterosexual
cuando un compañero de escuela nos dice
que le gusta una chica de otro año nos
está contando cuál es su orientación
sexual cuando leímos romeo y julieta
leímos sobre la orientación sexual de
romeo y julieta
la naturalización de la heterosexualidad
hace que pareciera que la
heterosexualidad no es nada no es una
orientación sexual y que las únicas
personas que tenemos orientación sexual
somos aquellas que lo vamos a expresar
de una manera diferente entonces cuando
vemos dos chicos de la mano dos chicas a
brazadas dos chicos o dos chicas que se
besan pareciera que estamos tocando una
campanita y diciendo hey acá estoy soy
gay soy lesbiana
soy trans soy bisexual y sin embargo no
estamos haciendo más que expresar
nuestra orientación del deseo afectivo y
sexual como cualquier otra persona
todas las personas tenemos una
orientación sexual y la experiencia
personal de la orientación sexual es
exactamente igual en cada una y cada uno
de nosotros en algún momento por algún
motivo nos gustan otras personas nos
atraen cuántas veces nos habrá gustado a
alguien y la familia nos dice no es para
vos no te conviene no nos gusta esa
persona con la que andas y nosotros
estamos ahí metidos y moss y no queremos
escuchar nada no sabemos bien porque no
sabemos bien por qué nos gusta tanto no
sabemos por qué nos quite el sueño no
sabemos por qué queremos averiguar sus
datos de contacto sus redes sociales su
celular encontrarlo o encontrar en el
barrio casualmente para poder acercarnos
y tal vez si hay coincidencia en esa
atracción poder iniciar alguna relación
o tener algún encuentro con esa persona
por tanto todas las personas tenemos
orientación sexual el proceso personal
es el mismo pero sin duda la experiencia
social la valoración social la mirada
social en relación a las distintas
orientaciones sexuales es diferente aún
hoy seguimos en una sociedad que sigue
valorando de distinta manera a las
personas de acuerdo a la orientación
sexual que expresa
yo les conté entonces varios aspectos de
mi vida
les conté también obviamente que soy un
varón gay que estoy casado pero para
poder reflexionar un poquitito más en
relación a esta experiencia de la
orientación sexual me gustaría invitar
las invitarlos a hacer un ejercicio
invito a quienes están en esta sala y
que sean heterosexuales los gays
lesbianas bisexuales están en la sala
están exentos del ejercicio a que
cierren los ojos un minuto cierra los
ojos
vayan a la infancia a la adolescencia
traten de traer sus recuerdos personales
traten de recordar
si hubo algún hecho concreto que
desencadenó su heterosexualidad
si hubo algún momento específico en el
cual descubrieron que eran
heterosexuales
cómo fue ese día en el cual
sentaron a papá ya mamá a la mesa y le
contaron papá mamá soy hetero
pueden identificar esos momentos
seguramente no seguramente no porque la
experiencia de la heterosexualidad se
vive no se explica no se cuenta no se
visibiliza en una sociedad
mayoritariamente o más frecuentemente
heterosexual solo hace falta vivir y
expresar nuestra sexualidad sin
explicarla de alguna manera si funciona
el proceso personal en relación a la
sexualidad pero por qué es tan relevante
esta diferencia en relación a la
orientación sexual de las personas o
porque aún hoy sigue siendo un tema
relevante
porque a lo largo de la historia durante
muchísimo tiempo se gastaron enormes
recursos y vidas humanas en intentar
explicar por qué algunas personas son
heterosexuales y por qué algunas otras
personas no lo somos incluso
recientemente en un estudio genético
conducido por la universidad de harvard
y el massachusetts institute of
technology el mit
muy conocido se encuestó y se trabajó
con 500.000 personas tres ciudades de
san nicolás prácticamente 500.000
personas estudiadas para lograr
encontrar el gen que determine la
orientación sexual de las personas
saben cuál es ese gen
ellos tampoco tiraron un montón de plata
a la basura porque el estudio determinó
que no hay un gen
que determine la omm o la
heterosexualidad
no hay algo que venga en una marca sino
que evidentemente la orientación sexual
es producto de una serie de factores los
cuales no se pueden aún identificar y de
alguna manera tampoco será tan relevante
identificarlos no para qué nos sirve
saber esto y por qué no mejor
concentrarnos en entender que sabemos en
el mundo heterosexuales gays lesbianas
bisexuales y personas trans transexuales
será porque la sexualidad se expresa de
manera diversa la sexualidad tiene
distintas expresiones y lo que tenemos
que hacer como sociedad es trabajar para
que esa expresión no determine ningún
tipo de barrera y ningún tipo de
discriminación y esto es importante
porque tenemos que lograr ya no respetar
al que es diferente a la que es
diferente sino celebrar la diversidad
que presentan nuestras sociedades y
nuestras comunidades
esas diversidades que nos enriquecen que
nos hacen más plurales que nos hacen más
democráticos que nos hacen más libres
y que le ahorran muchísimo sufrimiento
inútil a tantas personas para no seguir
generando le sufrimiento a tantas
personas para no seguir viviendo bajo la
forma de la discriminación para no
seguir segregando a quien es distinto
por cualquier motivo o circunstancia
personal es que creo y comparto con
ustedes es fundamental que aprendamos a
vivir en sociedades que celebran la
diversidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]